y
por quinto día consecutivo los
manifestantes volvieron a las calles en
las mayores protestas vistas en mí al
martes de hace más de una década
desafiando la prohibición de reunirse
miles de personas marcharon este
miércoles contra el golpe militar en la
mayor ciudad del país
rangún la escalada de la violencia de
las autoridades no ha debilitado la
determinación de los manifestantes los
militares están tomando medidas brutales
contra nosotros pero los jóvenes
dirigirán las protestas de forma
pacífica seguiremos luchando contra el
régimen
todo el mundo tiene miedo en este
momento y no queremos sentirnos así toda
la vida por eso protestamos
pacíficamente a pesar de nuestro miedo
mientras tanto los militares siguen
reforzando su control del poder
los soldados asaltaron el martes la sede
del partido de la líder detenida en sal
succi durante el toque de queda nocturno
en todo el país la redada se produjo
después de que decenas de miles de
personas que se manifestaban en todo el
país fueran recibidas por la fuerza la
policía desplegó cañones de agua y gases
lacrimógenos en la capital naypyidaw
mientras que se realizaron
de advertencia antes de lanzar balas
contra los manifestantes los informes
sobre varios heridos han suscitado una
fuerte condena por parte de naciones
unidas'
las protestas estallaron después de que
los militares hicieran con el control
del país a principios de febrero tras
unas elecciones que ganó el partido de
suu kyi la liga nacional para la
democracia el ejercito alegó un fraude
generalizado que ha sido desmentido por
la comisión electoral del país subs y
permanece bajo arresto domiciliario
junto con altos cargos del partido no se
le ha visto desde que se produjo el
golpe de estado la semana pasada